this is the child with single word you
wanna b to the degree of b
as I said when we hear some
single word in our Moscow
there is a whole process here they are
for linear equations
wiki bound by pots snow contextual
but if we learn a foreign language and  than
individual words in this language
, a very weak connection is created because
this word is taken out of context and your
iphone before
and junior dior let's say you, as Russian
people, learned English or extreme
platoon from in much condition
and imagine that you would read a text in
which there is  word duck the best reactions
hall sotheby's he so interview data
besides this text could be
could could be some situation
that happened to you market and
imagine that you are running in the park very
beautiful weather a
tribute to the office and valine then you
ran out of breath  took my breath away
you stop me up on a lake that's why you
stopped near the lake of russia before I save it
full film love takes me nowhere saw
this beautiful  a new family of ducks that swim
on the water of
young domains
yusin chose a pitcher and will not belittle and it
seems to you that they are swimming in a very big
idyll
you get a beautiful picture from the
context of the min stage channel are you on such
wanna rock the house and what else has never been
like this and  there is a context you remember
not just the word duck you remember the whole
situation in which it
is, but an even better example of a very beautiful
girl bocking you are a beautiful girl from
history maybe I tell that
so far I have been in central park she
has you dared I met a very beautiful
a girl from food lookin' for example
our sprint backlog
and it was a very interesting case
because she was looking at a big duck
beating
this duck uttered strange sounds
koryakov
going that the prince was the date of the vessel and
so I stopped and thought and
said strange duck and speak in  which
you later
but I am an American trying in English
drag the small sun
right duck she smiled at me and said
yes str  this duck
and I was looking for sorry I don’t understand you
Indiana capital return from yours and then I
found out that she is Russian to what
pizza duck chicken duck dived
and then she started repeating the words duck
duck she couldn’t speak English
well I’ll kill you foxwell
and this one  the girl was so beautiful when
i was aida sarena yours that i decided to learn
russian
dead can dance and silk and i am sure that
this guy who tell this
story about duck duck and ford starslife
will remember the words duck all his life
ashamed through the context of emotions of life
is not  just a neutral context this is an
emotional context this is a life
penguin go in ancient
rome chapter 1 of the imf m life people said we do not
learn at school we learn in the process of
life and this is what happens to us
when we learn our native language and
when we learn other languages  ekans
this information from machines
we learn from the situation from emotions and
control and context weasel would share the ural
show and beaufort
let's go back  in addition to the fact that I showed
nokia earlier in an arc my sport means
when we looked at the words we were
only here this upper part of the building
vr come here
is embedded in a big way way context
emotions
in fact we have more that in
fact all our processes  built into
a larger frame all our processes
are in context in the emotional
context show you belong in contact
so when we have a lot and words
it is best to learn it in context
I want to drain it from you and what else does
xp for sale in life account teach and
associate this word  with a situation, it
could be the context itself, or it could
be a situation from life and I want my
onhandleintent if you consciously or
unconsciously learn something and the
emotional bow would riff up yet you have
an emotional connection with
this information he played just on
morphine is great and it helps you
remember better